bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti questo
video sono parigi oggi siamo tornati
siccome domenica sul nuovo episodio di
devo fare una sigla decente magari vabbè
dai sua assoluta jong air games e questa
cosa mi fa impazzire partiamo distretto
1 albus silente è bradley cooper
distretto 2 cracco e daniel dei punt
hellas che rientra in gioco da un po che
non lo mettevo 33 d'eril dixon e del cui
distretto 4 11 e demi lovato non
c'entrano niente l'uno con l'altro di
105 haring haggar e fede distretto 6
freddie mercury e katy perry questo
successo i capelli che ti per distretto
7 fa vj e ron weasley non si sa chi dei
due è più combattivo probabilmente ron
weasley distretto 8 locchi e luigi di
maio che un pochettino si somigliano se
non fosse per tutto il corpo distretto 9
miley cyrus e mister bean anche loro si
somigliano il freddo di aci news
cavalleri e nick jonas
il 7 11 ninja e più di fi e per finire
ovviamente mi sento 12 pt che gli hunger
games abbiano inizio lei pantella scappa
la cornucopia deadpool katniss miley
cyrus litigano ma il science uccide
trionfalmente entrambi katniss morta
immediatamente è durato un secondo demi
lovato pugnalata da new scamandro alla
schiena con un tridente o vj prendono
zaino non rendendosi conto che vuole
cosa c'è in quella tescari cosa sai di
me lo era e gr fungere la cornucopia
freddie mercury afferra un barattolo di
escada face di escada pesca governo
scioglilingua mentre pita contiene
attrezzi da pesca vita mister bean e
loki tese pese ai tempi tese
un'imboscata senza successo a ninja
luigi di maio fenin ercoli che invece li
uccidono quindi sono morti p da mister
min e l'on
nick jonas scatena un'esplosiva
uccidendo familiari perché non so
giocare a questo gioco perché otto colpi
di cannone possono essere ascoltato in
lontananza piscina morta katniss youth
scamandro 11 p ta mister bean
e fa vincere porco luigi di maio uccide
miley cyrus per le sue scorte il reddito
di cittadinanza di miley cyrus albus
silente avvelena la bevanda di freddie
mercury ma la sbagli e per se stessa e
muore una cosa che mai si rende avrebbe
fatto perché troppo intelligente per
katy perry canticchia silenziosamente
freddie mercury trafigge katy perry con
un ramo di un albero perché musica
cracco riceve acqua pulita all'anno
scorso sconosciuto masterchef te lo dico
io sono morti in tre ma elitario salvo
silente e katy perry
nick jonas freddie mercury era jaeger
anni imbattuto senza successo più di poi
daniele vanterà se demi lovato che
invece li uccidono quindi sono morti
nick jonas che mi ha ammazzato quindi se
lo merita freddie mercury e è rilegga
bradley cooper muore per ipotermia
americans l'aper del mio cesso proprio
però weasley si aprì che si arrampica su
un albero per riposare fede si cerca di
curare la sua infezione la cornucopia
viene rifornita di cibo scorte armi e
memorie dei famiglie delle famiglie dei
tributi che gliene frega a quelli
rimasti vivi delle memorie dei delle
famiglie dei tributi senza te frega
vince a partita ma che sta guarda la
foto di mia madre sono agli hunger games
fedeltà raccoglie più cibo in una borsa
che può prima di fuggire
luigi di maio decide di non andare alla
festa ninja decide di non andare alla
festa per gli pare ci devono andare a
definire questa è un'altra lotta cracco
cade in un lago ghiacciato e annebbia
uno sciame di cacciatori glieli agli
inseguitori invade la rena che sono
quelle ripeto quelle ap pungiglioni
gigante lì poi sopravvive fedez e ron
weasley finiscono i posti percorrere
sono in punto di morte mentre fugge
dagli inseguitori luigi di maio afferra
ninja e lo getta a terra
altro che politica lui happy four nights
gioca fornet dieci colpi di cannes
guanti morti in un giorno
nick jonas freddie mercury era jaeger
bradley cooper demi lovato cracco daniel
pantella sfide ron weasley e ninja
visualizza lo stato di tutti sollevati
dividere il dixon di maio che ha fatto 5
kill di maio più di peider il dixon e
luigi di maio sono i finalisti signori
giorno 4 li pretende alle ferite di
david dixon quindi si sono alleati luigi
maio scopre un fiume luigi di maio più
di paia derrickson iniziano a combattere
tutti e tre ma più di pais k mentre
luigi di maio uccide d'eril dixon
finale incredibile tra di maio e più di
paia caso luigi di maio sopraffà più di
pai uccidendolo incredibile ha fatto 7
chi l'ha vinto luigi di maio ma come
come ha fatto a fare 7 kill di maio
ma com'è possibile ninja ha battuto dei
dx tutti mica un fenomeno fa politica
val killer
cos'è e stata una battaglia pesante ma
sei stato bravissimo a sopravvivere e
niente grande gigino bravo gigino mi è
piaciuta provare un'altra mi sono
divertito però sono molto quasi per
primo ma perfetto come sempre
ragazzi questa è questa è difficile non
so perché tutti sono belli gazzoni di
tutti quanti quindi procedere nextgame
mentre i tributi stanno sul podio suona
il corno loki trova più di pai nascosto
nella cornucopie lo uccide la vj fugge
dalla cornucopia ragazzi gran notizia
non sono morto il primo turno daniel
fante las prende una manciata di
coltelli da lancio l'agguerrito al
daniel 11 rompe il naso di fede per un
cestino di pane luigi di maio fugge
dalla cornucopia vediamo come siamo
andati in questo turno incredibile
adesso che non sono morto in amore
nessuno 11 tende alle ferite di fede ma
come gli appena spaccato la faccia come
possibile dalle battella spesca luigi di
maio roba da lotti mentre non sta
guardando crack uccide d'eril dixon con
una falce cosa che usava per affettare i
pomodori katniss avvelena la bevanda
didn't un label lo beve e muore quindi
del pool è morto complimenti i tecnici
ecco di solito muoiono in dieci in
undici sono molti sono in tre ma che
strano proprio perché io sono
sopravvissuto tremorti pd peider il
dixon e piscina morta che sfiga se ti
perdi convince albus silente a
rannicchiarsi con lei lo conosco le
gemme freddie mercury lancio un coltello
nel petto di ron weasley qua ci sono io
sono già pronto a morire fa anche rima
fakih jr jaeger e demi lovato discutono
di giochi e di cosa potrebbe succedere
al mattino invece no luigi di maio
rintraccia uccide daniel dei fan della
somma per chi è che ti perdi uccide
katniss per le sue scorte mio dio
demi lovato steli fa vigili ma solo di
restelli
non fatevi della traduzione originale
giusto per curiosità talk sa di vino
atomi stalker a temi l'ora ma magari tre
colpi di carro non muore nessuno in
stanger games che succede lo è possibile
ninja cade in un lago ghiacciato annega
ecco come non de pità costringe freddie
mac
a uccidere cracco miley cyrus si rifiuta
di uccidere quindi pita lo uccide invece
quindi è morto freddie mercury pita
avanza accidentalmente su una mina ma
perché capita dai già esperienza perché
queste cose
demi lovato katy perry e nick jonas
allegramente cantano canzoni insieme
picchia che tutto dice quando non è un
duetto mentre persone un trucchetto un
trito un dritto fantastico duo out parte
che nick jonas e demi lovato a cantano
insieme dai tempi dei camp rock
luigi di maio demi lovato e mister bean
litigano demi lovato i cinesi con
fallimenti entrambi demi lovato è
riuscito a uccidere luigi di maio e il
killer per eccellenza va bene grande
limite è sopravvissuta e mi stalker che
non so se è un bene a questo punto
nick jonas attacca fa vigeva basta che
cosa c'è contro di me nick jonas sarà
perché mi stalker a demi lovato ma
perché ciò con me riesce a fuggire se
riuscite a fuggire sono vivo tre colpi
di cannone vogliono sempre tre persone e
reja garko non convince famiglia da
calcolarsi con lui ebbe dai non vedevo
l'ora
nick jonas fa esplodere uccidendo katy
perry cracco in yoox cam under
mamma mia 11 ascolta fa vj e nick jonas
che porta che parlano in onda ma se la
tenda dle uccidermi un secondo fa ma
cosa quattro colpi di cannone 34 morti
pazzesco katy perry crack con il
scamandro e miley cyrus procedere inizia
a sottrarsi alla lista dei rimanenti
albus silente muore cercando di scappare
dall arena
vabbè non dicevo che si tengono per mano
e relega lucide bradley cooper con
un'accetta
nick jonas spara una freccia fede ma
manca e uccide invece demi lovato no
la vj chiede aiuto come è morta a
stalker però vabbè direte effettivamente
era una bella storica 15 chiederei aiuto
di jonas ledha e se vuole mazza fa vj
singhiozza mentre stringe una foto dei
suoi amici e della sua famiglia ma
lavori vorrei replicare la scena ma non
ho fatto di miei amici abbraccio questa
fanta no chi muore è rai e gr ferisce
gravemente fa vj ma lo mette fuori dalla
sua misera coni non sono morto sono in
tre
no sono morto
e sono volto dai dovete fuori dalla sua
miseria che sono fuori dalla mano alla
miseria nel senso alla mia vita la
miseria quindi se lo mette fuori dalla
sua misera vita capito che schifo biala
braccia la fanta quindi show down finale
tra e rene 11 31 vincite ray hunger
games era intenta di scalare un albero
ma accade ma da ieri puoi far vincere 11
così dai ci hanno ammazzati tutti poi
una caduta dall'albero che l'ha vinto ma
dai ma dai non cos'è vincitore 11 del
distretto con potevi non arrampicarti
ieri ha vinto 11 a caso non ha fatto
niente
una chi l'ha fatto da ieri non ho fatto
neanche un pò come forte e ci arrivò in
finale ma non faccio anche un archivio
uguale ragazzi questi erano gli hunger
games di oggi spero vi sia piaciuto è
comunque tanta roba è tanta roba i
ragazzi sono si stanno sfilando un po
tutti ma soprattutto di maio avrei mai
detto però ok ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto persona gli hunger games con la
sensi
finalmente mi piace se non sei da codici
di al canale iscrivetevi e noi ci
rivediamo come sempre ha proseguito
d'aria
[Musica]
ma